the trans day of vengeance is coming up
on Friday
I was explaining this to some family
members they didn't believe me
I said what is this what's this security
risk that is apparently cropping up I
said oh there's a day called the trans
day of Vengeance they said oh haha
what's it really called
so it's really called the trans day of
Vengeance and it's being promoted by
fairly large accounts on social media
and it's a call for violence against
anyone who dares to suggest that a man
is not a woman and a woman is not a man
and it's being pushed specifically in
Washington DC and Tennessee and it's
being directed specifically at the daily
wire and these transgender
activists are
in some cases calling for a very
explicit violence in some cases I mean
there are videos that I'm not even going
to play on this show that have gone
viral of people essentially saying that
the Christian School deserved what it
got because they they didn't accept
transgender ideology hideous stuff and
uh but but even the ones who are trying
to not get kicked off of social media
they are very clearly calling for
violence against people who disagree
with them trans people in Tennessee it's
time to fight trans allies in Tennessee
it's time to fight trans women if they
lock you up for identifying as a woman
fight resist you're gonna die anyways
we're going to die anyways it's time to
resist fight them hurt them
if they put their hands on you beat them
we are at an attack it's time to fight
back do you hear me
trans people in Tennessee transmit trans
women non-binary fight if they try to
arrest you have you arrested or a felony
for existing
felony for existence notice she she
keeps prefacing all of this with if if
if but the ifs are totally implausible
if they arrest you on a felony for
existing
what does that mean nobody is suggesting
that I'm starting to it's not a woman
too right it's a dude I assume I'm
starting to think this fellow might be a
little bit confused
huh
starting to think something might be a
little bit off about this guy
usually I don't take threats all that
seriously because people mouth off on
social media and it's no big deal but
the reason I don't take them seriously
is because most people are at least
somewhat reasonable in the end they
might mouth off a little bit but
eventually they come to their senses
people who have lost their senses people
who have lost their capacity to reason
about even the most basic things they
don't get reasonable again
until they receive
psychological and spiritual help which
is being explicitly denied them by our
law and by our popular culture keep
going getting together get people who
agree with you to come and fight
carry a weapon at all times and yes you
have to attack the police officer
attack everybody fight fight fight fight
carry a weapon at all times you know the
Second Amendment is a right
the ability to defend oneself is a right
but as the libs always like to point out
these rights are not totally absolute
existing in a vacuum they are
conditioned by certain things and
predicated on certain things so you have
you have a right to vote you have a
civil right to vote but if you commit a
felony if you commit number of
infractions you can lose that right to
vote
you have a right to free speech but you
don't have a right to threaten people
that would be an abuse of speech that
would be speech that undermines speech
that would be a speech act that is that
is not tolerated
you have a right to a gun
felons lose their right to guns all
sorts of people lose their rights to
guns
it I I am as strong a defender of the
right to defend yourself in the Second
Amendment as possible
if you
have demonstrated a capacity and
incapacity to reason
if you are not capable of rational
Behavior
certainly that would be one of the
reasons why you could not own a gun this
is why five-year-olds are not allowed to
go into the gun store and buy guns they
haven't reached the Age of Reason yet
and people can lose their reason for all
sorts of reasons
and unfortunately what we do in this
Society now is we call
we call sanity insanity and Insanity
sanity you want to talk about social
media censorship I discovered last night
that I had been banned from Twitter
I am suspended until I delete a tweet I
said me what did I say
I guess I say controversial things
sometimes I don't think they're really
controversial but in our crazy culture
they are so what what was the offending
tweet that got me suspended
I kid you not
I was suspended from Twitter
for quoting the Bible
only quoting the Bible I didn't it was
in a quote tweet about vengeance but I'd
all I said
was a direct quote from the Bible I was
quoting Saint Paul who himself was
quoting Deuteronomy and here's the
kicker
my my citation here was
beloved never avenge yourselves but
leave it to the wrath of God for it is
written vengeance is mine I will repay
says the Lord
so
for quoting the Bible
saying do not avenge yourselves I have
been suspended for violating Twitter's
rules against
violent speech
because Up Is Down
and men are women
and peaceful speech
speech urging piece is now considered
violent
wouldn't it be great to give the
government a ton of power to do that now
what could go wrong
they're so reasonable aren't they
no so what do they do the the government
does this a lot they will advance a
piece of legislation with really
innocuous sending terms a really popular
sounding terms ban Tick Tock yeah tick
tock's terrible okay let's ban it and
then the bill doesn't even address that
just an excuse to take more power and to
to take more control over our political
order
speaking of excuses we've been talking a
lot obviously about the shooting here in
Nashville we'll get to a little bit more
of that later and what we're learning
now but there was another shooting
fairly recently this was in Denver a
student shot two School administrators
uh not fatally I think the the
administrators are going to be okay
Nancy Pelosi jumped in on that and said
quote
today it was my privilege to stand with
Brave Young activists for gun violence
prevention because generation lockdown's
leadership has been crucial to our fight
we must renew the assault weapons ban to
protect America's children okay this is
the same sort of line that the Democrats
are always pushing but in the case of
the Denver school shooting
the shooter used a handgun
an assault weapons ban wouldn't do
anything to stop that shooting
even the term assault weapon doesn't
really mean very much of anything at all
it's just a rifle that has aesthetic
features that make it look a little
scarier but even that is just a
euphemism to it's a slogan to try to
instill fear in people but
but in the case of this Denver shooting
it's completely disconnected
which is why I made the point yesterday
the the one thing we know that these
shootings are not about is the guns
because the guns haven't really changed
in 100 years
a lot of other things have changed our
approach to mental health our
understanding of spiritual reality our
relation to our political institutions
those have all changed dramatically
after the social revolution of the 1960s
in particular and in the last several
decades it's ramped up
but the Democrats will always blame the
gun
which which is the one thing we know
hasn't really changed is the one thing
we know can't really explain this
increase in these shootings
because they don't want to address the
deeper causes they bear responsibility
for these deeper causes
and they also don't want to change it
they want to continue to call Insanity
sanity they want to continue to redefine
into abolition or basic political
institutions they want to continue to
corrupt our basic political institutions
they want to continue to deny spiritual
reality and they want to call good evil
and evil good
so of course they have to ban the guns
there's nothing else for them to ban or
there's nothing else for them to point
to
there's nothing else for them to talk
about
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it if you are not a
member
go to dailywire.com
use code knows to check out for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign